président français a profité de sa venue
à vilnius pour s'entretenir avec
svetlana tirano sky à figures de
l'opposition en biélorussie et exilé en
lituanie elle assure le soutien entier
du président français ont fait le point
sur cette rencontre avec notre
correspondant antoine claireaux antoine
bonjour comment s'est passée cette
rencontre entre le président français l
opposante below russe oui bien le
président français et l'opposant de le
rue se sont rencontrés pour ce qui a été
d'après cette dernière un échange franc
et honnête
afin de trouver une issue à l'élection
présidentielle controversée du 9 août
dernier
emmanuel macron ainsi proposé à son
interlocutrice la médiation de la france
et de l'europe notamment via le web fait
la nature à loos callas se réjouit pour
sa part d'avoir reçu le soutien du
président français écouter le président
français a promis de tout faire pour
nous aider à négocier et à trouver des
solutions dans la crise biélorusse il
nous assure son soutien et cela est très
important pour nous tous nous avons reçu
une invitation à prendre la parole
devant le parlement français et nous
l'avons accepté l'opposante delerue se
réfugier en lituanie espère aussi voir
emmanuel macron user de ses bonnes
relations avec vladimir poutine pour
obtenir une transition pacifique en
biélorussie le président russe s'est
également une fois de plus exprimé sur
le dossier biélorusse en rappelant les
liens qui unissent les deux pays mais
aussi les tentatives de pression
extérieure de ces dernières semaines et
coûter est actuellement compte tenu de
la situation difficile dans laquelle
s'est retrouvée la biélorussie notamment
à cause de pressions extérieures sans
précédent
après l'élection présidentielle je tiens
à répéter que les relations entre la
russie et la biélorussie résiste au
passage du temps et aux circonstances
changeantes et repose sur des bases
solides car nos états sont liés par
d'étroites relations culturelles et
spirituelles enracinée dans la durée
ainsi que par des relations familiales
et parental et une histoire commune
emmanuel macron on est bien conscient et
soutient ostensiblement l'opposante
russe comme on vient de le voir mais il
connaît tout le poids de moscou dans
cette affaire d'ailleurs il a dit
lui-même en arrivant en lituanie lundi
soir la russie est un interlocuteur
incontournable
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux pour
toutes ces précisions punk l'hérault en
direct de moscou